if you're a content creator looking for
a device dated 4K 6K AK video Adobe
Premiere After Effects DaVinci Resolve
this may not be the product for you if
you're a gamer and all you care about is
drop frame rates while you're playing
this is not the device for you if you
are someone who's not in a bleeding edge
technology and you like to go over
something more tried and proven this may
not be the product for you however if
you are in the content consumption
someone who loves to watch Netflix
YouTube Disney Plus Hulu you'd like to
browse the web look at your PowerPoint
presentations you'd like to see your
emails and on beautiful large display do
some live photo editing some live video
editing this may be the product for you
and if you're someone who likes to bring
a product to a client's office for a
presentation and make them go what is
that that looks awesome then this may be
the product for you I've been testing
out the Zen book a full 17 and Joel LED
for the past few weeks and I have fallen
in love with this device even though it
has shortcomings and it is a first gen
somewhat of a prototype product if you
would call it that but I love where Asus
is going with this this is the future
future of laptops and it has made me
really excited to see where this form
factor goes in the next couple years I'm
not going to talk about specs because I
did a previous video on that but what
I'm going to talk to you about is what
it's like to use on a daily basis the
pros and the cons because there are some
cons of this thing okay so let's get
down to talking about that first and
foremost how I use a laptop when I'm not
in the studio here because I have my
MacBook Pro M1 Max which I'm using to
edit these videos and sound design and
images and all that kind of stuff when
I'm not doing that what I tend to do is
just browse the web like most people I
watch a lot of YouTube I do watch the
Netflix I edit photos on Lightroom a
little bit on Photoshop as well I'll use
luminar AI depending and that's how I
sort of use my laptop on a daily basis
for me I gotta say that it handles most
of those tasks pretty well there are
some times that it does stutter I mean
it's a it's a 12th gen Intel i7 u-chip
so it's meant for a power efficiency not
power performance you will notice at
times that if you try to stress this out
it won't hold up but if you go into it
going look this is going to be like a
daily laptop for me like a work laptop
if I'm gonna do PowerPoint presentations
emails open up some documents watch some
content it's gonna be more than adequate
for you right now in terms of battery
performance on this if I'm doing a lot
of photo editing where the screen's on
constantly and I'm doing a lot of tasks
then the power is going to drop
significantly and I would get about four
to five hours if I'm kind of just doing
medial tasks about six to seven
thereabouts it's not too bad it's not
going to be a class leading performer
out there but it will do the job you got
to take in consideration the form factor
on this the battery the processor
everything is inside this very
relatively thin
17.3 inch display so it's not going to
be a Powerhouse in any respect but it
will do the job that you need it to do
you do need to charge the keyboard
separately from the Zenbook fold which
is a little bit of a hindrance at times
because do you bring two Chargers I mean
what do you do there's been times where
I was using this and the keyboard died
on me then I ended up having to use the
screen keyboard which isn't a deal
breaker because it is touch be nice if
there was induction charging so when you
do put the keyboard on to the full do
the magnets that it would actually
charge the keyboard itself so you didn't
have to worry about that so you plug in
one port and it charges everything
perhaps they'll do that in gen 2. let's
talk about that keyboard for a second
here now the key travel is actually
quite nice on this the trackpad's pretty
decent it's not the worst I've tried on
Windows devices but it's not the best
but it does do the job quite well
speaking of which though when you are in
laptop mode it's a little bit
unfortunate because it does sort of make
it a bit thick so if I'm going to try to
show this to you right here okay you can
see how thick that is so you might think
well is that really that bad Bobby when
you consider it your hands got to go up
a little bit higher than normal so now
laptops have gotten thinner and it's
made more comfortable for the wrist so
what I tend to do I tend to take the
keyboard off and I just set it here on
the table and it makes it much more
comfortable for me to type and that
allows me to also make this display
going from 12.5 inches when it's folded
up to now
17.3 inches and you actually have
yourself a desktop workstation because
everything is inside the display your
keyboard is connected via Bluetooth you
can connect a mouse via Bluetooth so you
are going to be good to go and you have
two Thunderbolt 4 ports on here but they
are placed in a very odd position no
matter which way you go you got one on
top and one on the side and you want to
go into laptop mode one on top and one
on the side and it's kind of going why
didn't you just put them both on the
side food for thought maybe Gen 2 and
you do have a headphone jack yes you do
because sometimes we want a headphone
jack but nowadays Bluetooth is getting
so good do we actually need it depends
if you're doing audio monitoring you
need a headphone jack in terms of the
camera on this this is what's
interesting the camera is good by the
way it's but it's on the side when you
have it in this position so it's only on
the top when you are going in laptop
mode okay then you've got your camera
right here right which is impossible if
you want to do this then you got to go
with the camera it's kind of a pain it's
not that easy to do with one hand I'm
trying to do it for this review but it's
not that easy then you gotta look on
this side and it's kind of reminiscent
of the iPad how they have that set up
there as well and it shoots in 1080
which is great you can adjust the
exposure uh white balance you can of
course set in different resolutions and
I'm looking to the side here because I
have it with the display Bluetooth
keyboard separate as I was mentioning
earlier I have to look at the side which
is a little bit odd it would be nice if
I had a camera here versus here but it
is what it is here's the quality and
it's not too bad what do you think in
terms of the crease on the display
you're wondering do you see it you do
see it I mean but when the screen's on
you don't really see it at all because
the screen is so bright and vibrant and
it's so beautiful to look at I mean you
don't even notice this crease at all it
just goes away I mean this display is
the star of the show and that's why I
really enjoyed using it is because it's
so bright it's so vibrant colors pop the
you know Dolby Vision Dolby audio I mean
it just the speaker systems sound great
on this thing it just is amazing to use
it's so good to watch content on this
thing it really is Asus makes some
really good displays and this foldable
OLED display is right up there this is
really really impressive so it is
plastic on the covering of this so if
you thought about using a stylus you can
but from what I understand you have to
use a stylus with a specific knob to the
front of it because it is plastic so you
don't want to scratch it versus glass
but you know again it's 17.3 inches so
maybe it's a little bit hard to do glass
at this point in time maybe Gen 2 they
will who knows but as a first gen device
it is begging for a stylus because
there's many times throughout this past
couple weeks I've been using it where
well this kickstand does have a little
bit of you can adjust the position on it
slightly from going straight up to on an
angle it'd be nice to kind of go down to
almost like using it to draw or you want
to sketch something or if you want to
show somebody something it'd be kind of
cool to do that you know what I mean
it'd be nice if they had that surface uh
kind of hinge that they've really
perfected over the years that was that's
really great and it'd be nice if they
could do that with this because that
would really help this out a lot but
overall the bezels on the side are
prominent there but they don't really
bother me so much because again you have
to have the keyboard magnetized to
adjust the camera system in there some
people will complain but then everybody
complains about something right but to
me the bezels do not get in the way
whatsoever because the screen is so
beautiful that you don't even notice the
bezels they just disappear when you're
just focused on your content and it's
just yeah it's absolutely amazing
besides the size and the weight and
carrying it around which can be a little
bit cumbersome and this sleeve here
which has no strap or handle to it which
is a little unfortunate that he's just
didn't include that and no pouch to put
the power cables in it by the way so you
gotta put that somewhere else it's it's
been fun and I have to save for a device
like this as I mentioned earlier this is
a bleeding edge technology first gen
device this is where laptops and tablets
are going to go into the future where
they're going to be a convergence device
where you're going to be able to it can
be what you want when you want it to be
and we're already starting to see that
now with the iPads and the surface
products for Microsoft but what Asus is
doing here is a Step Beyond it's just
they have to refine it but if you have
the budget and you have the means and
you're willing to take that risk you're
gonna have a lot of fun with this and I
think the moment that you open up this
display and you start watching content
you're going to be like holy cow man
this is fun to use and that's how I've
been for the last couple weeks I really
really enjoyed it it's gonna be sad to
give it back but that's part and parcel
with reviewing products you got to give
them back those are my thoughts on the
Zenbook full 17-inch OLED let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below are you looking to pick one up any
questions you have I'll try to answer
them for you I didn't talk about gaming
I didn't talk about any hardcore video
editing because this is not the device
for it as I mentioned earlier but
outside of that hit me up and I'll
answer those questions and if you like
this video check out more of our reviews
right here
thank you
foreign
[Music]